il
le maire de seix
et de pas non non
amer
je ne sais pas
c'est
vous l'avez reconnu c'est nathalie delon
25 une passion pour le cinéma est une
véritable fascination pour les bergers
malinois
c'est ma sai un malinois de 18 mois tout
à la fois un garde du corps comme un bon
ami et peut-être encore un peu
alors qu'est ce qui vous a intéressé en
choisissant un chien malinois
j'étais assez contre les malinois
pourront ils avaient l'air de le bâtard
de bergers allemands et c'est un
monsieur qui a fait découvrir cette race
et puis je suis allé chercher chez nos
élevages et si vous l'estimez que chez
eux c'est qu'ils ont un côté moins
servile un petit peu que les bergers
allemands ils sont entre eux le char et
le chien puis sont beaucoup plus sauvage
mais sauvage comme un chat s'il n'est
pas sauvage comme un chien méchant
ils ont été vraiment faits l'un d'eux
violents ou plus le stis n'ont pas vu un
seul tube baugé dire c'est la diligence
vraiment je sais pas c'est parce que
c'est pas ce qui est plus pur qu'elle
comprend vu comme ça le ballon comme ça
et puis surtout au quart de tour
mais à l'instant t rim tu peux y à
l'instinct la décision je crois que ça
parle beaucoup quand même parce que j'ai
pas voulu le faire rester si vous voulez
parce que ça m'intéresse pas en mesure
où il a suffisamment l'instinct pour me
servait justement à ce que je voulais je
voulais un chien et hasek soit sociable
tout en l'étant au quart de tour s'ils
les prêts à quelques fois je rentre jean
servat seul donc bien je suis pas
toujours accompagnée d'un garde du corps
mais c'est mon meilleur garde du corps
ça alors le gars du corium moi j'ai pas
tellement apprécié on s'est perdus quand
parce que j'apprécie
vous qui vous surveille kivu le
surveiller ceux de connivence km est
grande ce que j'aime avec ses chiens
c'est une énorme complicité qui à mai
mais qui s'établit tout c'est justement
parce que dès que je les prix pendant
six mois j'ai vécu avec ce chien gérant
conduisant la voiture comme un cas ou
dans mon besoin mais surtout toujours là
comme ça quand il était petit ce qui
fait rire
il croit jean thie est tout petit steve
erickson trompe l'oeil crevé mais je
dirais jamais tuer ce chien si les huit
premiers mois il était avec moi tout le
temps sans arrêt j'ai méchamment les
jeux des sorties le matin c'est un
esclavage cv mais après c'est
fantastique de le réguler
mais si merveilleux je dire il ya une
tendresse et une complicité existe pas
de la même façon que les bergers
allemands
à
ma famille
non
d'un côté c'est plus qu'un copain fait
attendre et vous voulez c'est un chien
qui est qui et uniquement mais c'est
aussi via les bergers allemands se prêta
comme ça aussi mais eux particulièrement
sont attachés à m personnellement vous
allez chercher dans un slip comme je lé
fais dire que je suis allé voir une
portée et j'en ai choisi gare et le
premier cap vers moi c'est lui je lui
disais tu choisis un peu oui
il est une serre défaite on aime
toujours les gens qui vous aiment et
voilà parce que le berger allemand
c'était un chien plus lourds qui est
peut-être mais un peu plus haute q pour
moi c'est une espèce de finesse aussi
bien physiques que morales pire lui par
exemple j'ai appris à marcher au pied
ont joué à prêt à s'asseoir où j'avais
appris dont on sent dans la vie parce
qu'on vous a vu un petit peu vivre que
vous aimez les gens qui comprennent très
vite
oui ça démarre très bon vous m'avez dit
on à j'ai eu beaucoup de chiens etc
on sait aussi que alain delon aime
beaucoup les chiens c'est lui qui va un
peu mieux communiquer cette passion pour
les chiens n'ont pas du tout dire allah
c'est vrai qu'il aime beaucoup les
chiens et ils avancent à pas pouvoir sur
les chiens mais j'ai toujours quand
j'étais gamine j'ai toujours des chiens
mais si vous voulez bon c'est lui
effectivement qui en dehors des charges
et quand j'étais môme c'est lui qui m'a
offert mon premier chien qui était
légalement et
et puis mon second celle aussi qui était
un berger allemand le coach déco zidane
avait 12
oh
et
bélisle à certains pouvoirs dont on est
par nature la poste les chiens un
pouvoir sur les chiens qui fait que je
suis très étonné par son passé avec ces
sauvages quand il avait à la première
fois mais c'était une tendresse paul
comme ça alors est ce que c'est la stat
qui sait que c'est parce que je leur
parlais langueur en levant il à l
autorité il attendrait ici là il adore
les charges et 10 rebonds depuis sa
salle
alors vous le chien ça marche pas du
tout le championnat où j'ai peur je sais
pas pourquoi j'étais un peu un peu
féline aussi alors ramené à chats
sociables d'envoyer vraiment parce que
vous le faites un métier sur des
plateaux aux tournées l'étude actrice
alors comment ça se passe on est vite ça
se passait très bien il mordait les
jeunes gens nés oui 1 et 2 qui sont
passés avec l'acteur s'était en italie
n'a et derrière bon il y avait par
exemple une scène d'amour et puis massa
est bon et est tout petit il avait six
mois et nous avons compris et elle pas
encore compris c'est une scène d'amour
et au moment où d'habitude jeudi à 6
d'art ils bouffent pas et puis on a eu
celle d'amour il a cru que la personne
agressée et s'y jeter sur lui
la deuxième fois alors que le sécher on
aiderait si mal mais quand on est
dressée lâchions les graisses par
exemple pour justement éviter qu'ils
aient peur d'une arme
on les dresser plus bruit de revolver et
la scène j'ai fait là en train de
regarder la scène ou france terre et
s'est jetée carrément sur sur la
personne qui tenait un revolver dans sa
main moi je m'y attendais pas me suis
dit ah si l'artiste n'est signalé marie
sander la sem eleonora qu'elle ne sait
pas c'est une très bonne actrice mais
les contrats que diminue rapidement et
que les cadres et
à
oui nathalie alors comment ça se passe
avec les deux chiens là il ya deux
personnalités complètement les féroé
c'est toi bah oui oui c'est à celui ci
est le chien si mais c'est pas vraiment
mon chien mais je l'aimé beaucoup parce
qu' il appartient à quelqu'un qui a vécu
qui vit souvent la maison qui me l'aise
quand ils n'ont pas été rares oui et
puis qui a sûrement une personnalité
très différente de la mienne
cela dit je crois qu'ils ont leur propre
personnalité de vincent et ses leaders
c'est le leader toutes chaînes abc et au
à sa manière du ministère avec les cas
et massaïs pour la sens et va l'enfant
chéri de la maison entre c'est à moi les
honneurs que j'aime bien chez eux note
le cnis
ils sont ils sont vraiment durs à
apprivoiser je ne ressens pas d'échec on
peut facilement
ils sont très très très ce genre de ceux
ci c'est pas la même foi si j'aime bien
ça si par exemple on vous disait massa
est bon il est plus là et si vous aviez
une autre race de chien je veux dire
qu'est ce que vous choisiriez même si
massa et épluchage sais pas si j'en
aurai à notre vraiment non mais c'est
vrai que je dirige et j'ai beaucoup aimé
si vous voulez me berger allemand que
j'avais avant c'est particulièrement un
chien pour m'a tuer qui s'appelait
charlie mais bon bah il est mort j'ai
beaucoup de peine mais massaï c'est
c'est quelque chose dans ma vie si vous
voulez qui est très très très important
mais soyez monfils qui passe avant tout
dire mais massage fois qu'il passe après
anthony